When you are trying to build hope, you
you cannot have hopeful people that are only
compliance-based.
It's just an oxymoron.
Can you tell us a little bit more
about, you know, why you started there with
this lack of hope that seems to be
hitting our world?
When you look at what actually gets people
to achieve goals and we need to have
people achieving some of the biggest
innovation goals that we've ever seen ever
yet in work history,
you need to have hope and I love
that I interviewed these military leaders
and this has been something that has hope
as a strategy has been a plan within
the military for a long time probably
50 or more years.
They've talked about how you can't send
someone out on a mission where they're
risking life or death unless that they have
hope that they are going to be able
to succeed. But Snyder's theory, which is
what I reference, is really it's about
having a goal but then having pathway
thinking. So you don't just have a plan
A and the only way is that, you
know, is is is straight to the to
the finish line.
And we all know that life is very
circuitous.
There's a lot of stuff that comes in
between us and our goals, and so his
theory is that we need to have a
plan A, a plan B, a plan C,
a plan D, and the more that we
sort of prepare,
, and the more we have agency and
autonomy to get to those goals, the more
likely we are to achieve them.
And also just in this era of hopelessness,
the latest world, , happiness report came
out, and everywhere in the world is happier
except for the West.
And when you look at like, you know,
Canada, US, UK, Australia,
it's really
disturbing, especially for young people.
Like you look in Canada, for example, and,
you know, you may be 24th ranking on
the list, but when you index for 25
and under, it's 71
is the ranking.
And in and in and in, , the
other Western countries, it's between 122
to 133
on the list of 168
countries. So, our youth and our Gen Z
that are about to make 30% of our
workforce
don't feel like they have a place in
the future of work.
How are you You know, we're so frustrated
and Gen Z are lazy, entitled.
They want well-being.
You know, what?
Have you given them a reason to feel
like they should be putting in, , their
time and investing in your company when you
know, right now we're seeing companies like
Meta tracking people so that they can make
themselves obsolete. I mean, that's the kind
of thing that's happening,
and we can't have it both ways.
We can't have, you know, our young people
feeling inspired and think about their
future when we are basically loudly telling
them that they don't have a future.
, and that I think that hopelessness is
something that we need to do a better
job of of leaders, or we're going to
lose
a very important pipeline of talent.
And if AI doesn't work out, I know
we put a lot of bets on that,
but if it doesn't work out, we're really
in trouble from an economic standpoint, and
our labor force is just going to be
completely shattered.
Where you talked about you know, layoffs,
right? And
When I read in the book, I thought
it was interesting how you positioned it
that sometimes some companies need to think
about doing these layoffs
and the impact on the remaining people.
Because say for example, and it made me
think I was talking about it actually with
my trainer at the gym and I said
it was a very interesting the way Jennifer
put it. Like say say for example, you're
saying we're going to get rid of 200
people in a 5,000 people organization.
Sometimes actually it might be better to
reskill those people, do something else as
because the uncertainty
and the stress that it brings for the
remaining people
is so high and it can mean they
don't take risks.
They don't come up with new ideas.
They're worried, right?
I thought that was I really I hadn't
thought of it that way ever before and
it was interesting the way you put that
in the
The reskilling and upskilling piece, we need
to be thinking more about and were
at a period of time until AI sort
of became
this blind spot.
I feel for us.
It's just it's become a blind spot and
and we have been talking the World Economic
Forum and you know, and the
ILO, we talk about this need for upskilling,
but our strategies haven't actually matched
to what we really need to be considering
because I keep saying, you know, if if
we do more upskilling and reskilling, A, you
have people that are going to just be
less detached from work.
They're going to be more likely to innovate.
They they won't feel like there's this fear
of obsolescence and so they're going to go,
"What's the point?" And they're they're
quiet quitting, and they're you know, or
they're like actually showing up with like
a plan to get other people to quit
along with them.
I mean, you don't want that kind of
toxicity.
So, you need to have people feel a
future, but we are again that betting
on AI being able to solve all these
roles, and we're seeing yet we haven't seen
yet like it really impacting productivity in
that way that from a GDP lens, the
way that we're measuring, it hasn't really
actualized. And so, we're better to say,
okay, let's bet on a future that it
includes humans, because if we don't include
humans, I mean, what are we going to
have? Just universal basic income
everywhere? Or is it going to be like
I think I wrote in the book,
you know, like is it going to be
like Wall-E where we're just like kind of
like all riding around on these like
floating whatever beds, and we're not going
to work? I mean, no one wants that.
This is such a dystopian idea of of
our future. And so much of what we
gain from happiness is a sense of
accomplishment and working.
So, you're going to have real issues and
drains with mental health.
And as I mentioned, too, violence because
people that are under
working it leads to more violence.
And so, we're just getting really
short-sighted. And and reskilling and
upskilling actually makes it so that people
and human beings still have purpose, and
there's still a usefulness,
and they will engage more in your in
your workplaces.
Yeah, and I I so agree with
you. I wrote down something from the
book. It's it's said avoid layoffs as
it kills hope for all in times of
economic uncertainty. Ensuring stable
employment can alleviate financial stress
and stress and promote psychological safety.
And you also you mentioned there
Charles Snyder, which I also pulled out
something from the book on that because
you know, I really liked you know,
he he saw hope as a cognitive
process characterized
by goals, pathways, and agency.
You touched on that a little bit a
second ago. I've actually sent
I've taken a photo of that part of
your book and sent it to a few
people over the last days last few days
because you know I do get a lot
of people mentioning they're like a bit down
and out and I just thought that was
I love you included that and I know
you touched on it a second ago but
Oh god, we need to get his his
stuff out to more people.
Goals, pathways, and agency.
I totally agree and you know what I
think is and I say this in my
talks. This is a regular thing in my
talks. I have this one slide and it's
you know Admiral McRaven for anyone that
hasn't seen his commencement address.
He's just this incredibly
amazing speaker and he has this commencement
address that says, "If you want to change
the world, make your bed." And his idea
is that and he's been in the
military and they always you know we're very
careful about how they made their bed and
and when you look at the actual the
science behind this the psychological
science is that when we accomplish small
goals when we start our day whatever that
day is whatever that time of day is
if we accomplish a small goal our brain
subconsciously
gets this this gear going that says, "Oh,
I did this small thing.
Now I can do a bigger thing." And
so when you think about someone that's
dealing with depression
like really serious depression a therapist
will say, "You know, just get out of
bed." You know, and the next thing is
it is make your bed.
Right now we need to in a state
of hopelessness have really small goals and
be celebrating small goals.
And at work stop celebrating the milestone
that you hit in a year celebrate the
day-to-day goals celebrate the weekly goals
the monthly goals
Experience. I know lots of people have this
experience of working for a micromanager
where you lose all agency
and it does impact hope.
Like I remember just thinking when I worked
for this total micromanager, I was like, "My
god, I have no energy to come in
here any day now because I've lost all
hope." And you just you shut down.
You really do because you don't feel any
sense of accomplishment if everything over
processed for you.
You know, when you're just complying,
it you don't feel good.
There's no intrinsic motivation
and why would we want to take someone's
intrinsic motivation away from them?
And you know, and I I talk
a lot about how you know, micromanagers
become micromanagers and a lot of it is
you know, a breakdown in communication.
A lot of it is they have expectations
on them and then when someone makes a
mistake and it impacts them, they become
very frightened or you know, people like if
you have a micromanager, I always say just
tell them what you're doing all the time.
You know, and then like just give them
a don't make it so they have to
come to you, go to them.
And I think that's the this whole issue
is that you know, micromanagers
sometimes they're born but a lot of a
lot more often they're made and so we
need we need to recognize that there's ways
to stop that but we also need
micromanagers to realize you're just you're
only making your job harder.
It it actually shows up in their toxic
and chronic stress so it makes them more
likely to burn out.
It's not helpful for them but when you
are trying to build hope, you cannot
have hopeful people that are only
compliance-based.
It's just an oxymoron.